this is the technical difficulties we're
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's chris joel
i thought to someone on train but it's
gone now
everybody's favorite gary brannon gary
browner so the anna just stopped up on
booth from the tescos had a massive dump
and went to sleep
and the bounty smell on the internet
matt greg and this is what a live studio
audience applauding sounds like
[Applause]
and today we are talking about acoustic
kitty
is it when you don't put the jack in
before you squeeze it
what acoustic kitten
electric it's kitty right yeah
yeah yeah you're playing
just grab the tail no that's that's
that's elevated kitty
yeah if you do the cat's tail they do
get generally a little bit higher
is it like some kind of loud bank
a car get out get out i'll just just
wear that one out get out
you're gonna have to explain that it's
like a kitty like a fund or something
yes it is
i got a boat today i'm all about the
groaning today
today may i say on behalf of us and the
entire ones you are the [ __ ] worst
oh hush surely every cat is acoustic
necessarily so since bob dylan
electrified his cat
you're actually in roughly the right era
so 1960s yep absolutely
and it's an actual cat yes it is an
actual cat but it's not like cats were
silent until the 60s it's not like
no one had ever i don't know surprised
one or stood on its tail or
actually not fed one because trust me
they are [ __ ] when they have not been
fed
oh no but until 1916 they used to have
another small account following them
around with a series of placards saying
meow on them
until one day the first car burped
[Applause]
right they found their first i just had
the worst and best idea at the same time
teach your cat to hook a little flag
onto its tail that says what it actually
means
how would you train the cat in the first
place it would need it would be the same
to say don't train me to hold up flags
can i just say in in the five seconds i
had there to work this [ __ ] out i had no
point that i thought this through that's
abundantly clear
right i thought oh you could do that by
the time you started going oh no no you
really can't it's fine
that's all the process of discovering
before you leave don't
nail flags to cats without considering
the kind of substances i did not mention
nails
i did not mention nails i said hook it's
a little thing like that like you get on
a
ring worm no i know the thing it's on
the top of an orange juice carton one of
those
yeah you want a ring
why not just nail it to the cat are
wrinkles for taking things off
yes but i'm finding another use for it
first buy your orange juice pull the tab
place to one side drink the orange juice
you cut the flag out of the orange
just like basically this is a cat
setting orange juice for the rest of its
life
on the one side it says orange juice on
the other side it says nothing it says
food
or toilet or i hate you or ow you're
gonna train the cat to get a different
one
yes i am they'll be they can't use the
scissors to cut out the orange juice
carton
you haven't thought this through i know
stop judging me i have all these ideas
all the time
you've managed to catch one in the end
of a second that idea existed as a thing
in my mind
anybody else want to take a swing just
while we've got it
amidst all that gary don't tell me he's
got a point
you were talking about terrible ideas
that briefly sounded like a good thing
and i'm giving you a point
yes
here we go isn't there a thing in monty
python where they hit mice to make a
instrument it's not an acoustic kitty
with you're thinking
the wrong way around here you're
thinking about production of noise
a listening cat espionage
so you feed the cat lsd to achieve mind
control
put on your tin foil hat and send it to
listen you've got
one part of that right it's not the lsd
or the tinfoil tinfoil cat
so they've strapped like a tape recorder
or something to a cat and let it wander
in places it's real to real
a big on the back how many of you the
point they did they did attach
something to it but it wasn't it wasn't
a big reel-to-reel tape it would be a
radio transmitter
rocket yes yes
it's gotta get there and they don't walk
far you're absolutely right you've also
used the word strap
i mean i'm giving you a point for radio
transmitter but strap is definitely not
implant
apparently i'm the sensible on this
episode
yes so me putting my cat in a dress for
medical reasons is weird
but but implanting a microphone in a cat
totes normal that's where today is going
for everybody
yeah in an hour-long procedure a
veterinary surgeon implanted a
microphone in the cat's ear canal
a small radio transmitter at the base of
its skull and a thin
wire into its fur
that's what the cat said did it did it
did i like the fact it said perfectly
normal looking cat after this apart from
the area with the red flag
who might have done that is it is it is
it is it is it russia
no is it is it is it america
yes it was the cia directorate of
science and technology how the hell
did the cia manage to out weird russian
intelligence
they probably didn't but we don't know
what the russians were up to because of
russian intelligence
were implanted microphones in cats the
russians were firing theirs into the icy
vacuum of space let's face it
with an even bigger antenna
uh yes it was it was a cia from america
the idea being that the cat would
wander into a place and just be
surreptitiously recording let me guess
the cat didn't want the way they wanted
it to wander
because it's a cat yes why did they have
to do another operation to uh to get
around
oh no this isn't the old one who
swallowed a fly is it i don't end up
sending an elephant in to distract from
my cat
they've invented by the way the cyberman
cap there incidentally yesterday because
they have replacing parts making them
bionic
yes what but how could you no i couldn't
go in grim places to what they had to do
to fix
they they bypassed the cat's sense of
hunger apparently oh
yes that was one of the problems with it
um the cia
really know what tuna sounds like
what cat seeds i've never fed one so how
much did this cost
to get to get a cat to do the research
well the cat's cheap
yeah to be fair the cat was probably
cheap but the the entire project here
according to uh victor marchetti former
ci officer how much should they spend
on a uh on a cat
was it was it a dollar sign with the
word ridiculous after it hang on prices
right rules yeah price is right right
okay yeah yeah we're in us dollars
us dollars in the 1960s it's about half
what what you have now
i'm gonna say half a million he's saying
half a million one million dollars now
we know what you do now
is he gonna do the one dollar bid or is
he gonna go high well i'm not going high
i was gonna say 150 000 but he pointed
to him first so right well
you're correct but you're not even close
20 million
dollars so they they got the cat
they know they implanted things in the
cat
where did they release the cat okay okay
not not surely not in the abroads no no
it was
it was it was in america i'll give you
that yeah if you want to see row if
there is such a thing yeah
new york yeah or something absolutely
right the soviet compound in washington
dc
the first the first mission was to
eavesdrop on two men in the park house
sorry parachute yeah
i'm i'm not entirely convinced that the
cat is going to be really good at
pulling its rip cord it's going from low
altitude i love the uh the wires
not so stupid now they released it
uh it it did wander towards the uh the
park bench what happened
died of hunger because they bypassed its
hunger center i was gonna say bye pass
the hunger center but go into the
kitchen and eat all the lovely tuna that
have been left cooling on a windowsill
or something like that
we flag up saying i'm a spy did it
immediately have a dump
yeah that's all it was recorded it is
sadly a little bit
uh a little bit harder hit my car yeah
immediately the the 20 million dollar
cat
was hit by a taxi uh almost immediately
these guys dark glasses you know dark
car parts over the compound
releasing the cat out of the boot of the
car good work agent and now
the the former director of the cia um
technical service
uh said that's that's an urban myth and
the actual problem with it was what
it walked off yeah training the cat i'll
give you the point for that yeah
uh the project was considered to be a
failure and a total loss
what happened to the cat well you just
said it got run over
does it have a proper military burial
well no this is the ultimate story this
is what the cia did it defect
to work for the other side i like that
idea because like clearly the russians
have better tuna it goes
it goes through the gate on the other
side is a russian blue welcome agent
if the russians had better tuna they
would be able to pick up
on the frequencies transmitted by it
[Applause]
according to that cia director what
happened to the cat once they ended the
program
did it just go and live with other
people all the time picking up on
hilarious conversations that could be
went into an excellent film now i've
just thought of it
there's a cracking kid's book in that
yeah yep the equipment was taken out of
the cat
the cat was re-sewn now hang on that's
that's two massive things you've just
skipped over there one
the equipment was taken out of the cat
it was a sentence that i'm
pretty hopeful would only be heard in
this room today
and the cat was sewn up yes yes it was
uh and lived a long and happy life
afterwards i'm going with hypothesis a
somehow
i can only imagine that it actually got
shipped off to port marion
and it's now wearing a little blue
blazer and being chased by just a normal
sized balloon down a beach
[Laughter]
it's
there is i have managed to pull up here
something from the actual
national archives of the united states a
a redacted
document about a cat what do they think
they could do with cats
distractionating while a better trained
animal actually goes and does the
listening thing well like a chimp with a
little microphone
and a suit yeah obviously got a blend in
fact just a small person we could even
use full-sized people
we could call them spies
that's a step too far agent okay
i suppose the only thing a cat can do is
just wander in and
unexpected and everyone be fine with
that yes you're absolutely right trained
to walk short distances
that was all that was 20 million dollars
and high-tech cat bug equipment to go
five meters
and only if they wanted to go that way
anyway again however
i'm quoting here the environmental and
security factors force us to conclude
that
for our purposes it would not be
practical
but damn it we try basically you know if
you've ever had
an essay where you know your conclusion
is terrible
yes but you have to write a conclusion
anyway
yeah the work done on this problem over
the years reflects great credit on the
personnel who guided it
particularly redacted whose energy and
imagination could be models for
scientific pioneers
i probably know the guy yeah there is a
connection here
uh to an article labeled remote control
animal what is that an animal used to
remote control or remote control of an
animal remote control of an animal
because the other way around these
pigeons and bombs
the brits did that yeah they put a
pigeon in a bomb and they made it peck
on yeah trained it to peck on cities
yes yeah yeah so they passed on a bit of
glass in which bit of cluster did pull
the lever which made the
bomb turn and then it it it went
down to the ground it landed
[Applause]
no it wasn't but like that's that's a
brilliant story yes it was bf skinner's
pigeon controlled guided bomb
how do you think that worked well for
the pigeon it sounds pretty either way
what did we call this weapon
incidentally uh project pigeon that's a
shame
so i was gonna go for the v oh did
churchill not like the idea is this one
of these where you could flick a coin on
a monday he'd like it on tuesday he'd
hate it
our problem was no one would take us
seriously
like we're gonna call it operation
hilarious pigeon whatever they call it
uh there was also
uh the bat bomb they attached uh
incendiary bombs to bats
and then dropped a casing with a
thousand bats on uh woodland
yeah incendiary bomb
thus but that small incendiary bomb
well like matches basically yeah yeah
but the idea being it was on somewhere
that had a lot of tinder and kindling
and if you you know if you have hundreds
of bats one of them is going to find the
target
that is horrific yes i like the fact
that the first time to test it they're
flying over the target they
pull the lever on the bomb by the bats
fly out and the bats are just hung
upside down in the bomber
and on the [ __ ] body just writes maybe
try night time or something like that
it's just a black and a white coat yes
yes that's
insufficiently motivated
it did apparently work astonishingly
enough what dropping a thousand small
incendiary bombs caused a fire
one is
they were more about distribution where
did it set fire to first
the back houses uh yes pretty much an
auxiliary air base where they were
testing they got away
it's not great
the bats incinerated the test range and
roosted under a fuel tank
fuel tank fuel tank yes it worked
it was effective and then computer
control came in a few years later
well that's where we started isn't it
this is a tangent can you imagine that
let's start
what caused the fire
how did the bat start to fire struck the
bomb to them
when i'm went in a fuel tank at night oh
for god's sake
what else have you done home in pigeons
no no no no no no
no salmon with warheads on oh [ __ ]
they're gonna come back
aren't they are there still bats out
there that have to be diffused over
there after the war
i i don't think bats lived that long
unexploded bat
did they evolve to have incendiary bombs
in them that's not how evolution works
yet tell that to the bombardier beetle
uh there is also and this this is a
brief and quite dark story we're going
to go with it anyway oh yeah because
that'll change the tone of the episode
the anti-tank
dog
[Applause]
[Laughter]
trained to associate the image of a tank
with food run towards it with bomb on
yeah
spot on yeah what was the uh well spot
was all over it by the end of it
there was one slight problem this is a
soviet plan what was the problem with
the plan because they actually got the
point of releasing
dogs on the battlefield ran towards
t-34s instead of tigers yes you're
absolutely right they were trained on
soviet tanks so
right right towards the soviet tanks i
am thick as
mints and even i can see where that's
going wrong right
just make a cardboard cut or a balloon
like that yeah there were some
successful deployments but they
eventually realized that was that was
not a great idea uh i think that may
that may have to be where we call this
because that massive downer well
i was going to say on that bombshell
at the end of the show congratulations
uh matt you win this one
yay very clearly you win this one
uh you win some rice raw fish and
seaweed in the shape of a luxury car
it's a sushi rolls royce
with that we say thank you to chris joel
bye then
together to matt gray
i've been tom scott we'll see you next
time
man that got dark yeah
you